we are told that the formula the formula
for finding the perimeter of a rectangle
is P is equal to 2l plus 2w where P is
the perimeter L is the length and W is
the width and just to visualize what
they're saying and you might already be
familiar with this let me draw a
rectangle and that looks like a
rectangle and if this sides length is L
then this sides length is also going to
be L and if this width is W then this
width up here is W and the perimeter is
just how what is the distance if you
were to go around this rectangle and so
that distance is going to be this W plus
this L Plus this W or that width plus
this length and if you have to if you
have a 1w and you add it to another W
that's going to give you 2 WS so that's
2 W's and then if you have 1 L and then
you have another L that's going to give
you if you add them together that's
going to give you 2 LS so the perimeter
is going to be 2 l's plus 2ws they just
wrote it in a different order than the
way I wrote it
but the same thing so hopefully that
makes sense now their question is
rewrite the formula so that it solves
for width so it solves for width so the
formula the way it's written now it says
P is equal to something they want us to
write it so it's dubbed this W right
here they want it to be W is equal to a
bunch of stuff with with ELLs and peas
in it and maybe some numbers there so
let's think about how we can do this so
they tell us that P is equal to 2 times
L plus 2 times W we want to solve for W
well a good starting point might be to
get rid of the L on this side of the
equation and to get rid of it on that
side of the equation we could subtract
the 2l from both sides of the equation
so let's do it this way so you subtract
2l over here minus 2l you're also going
to have to do that on the left hand side
so you
have minus 2l we're doing it on both
sides of the equation remember an
equation says P is equal to that so if
you do anything to that you have to do
it to P so if you subtract 2l from this
you're gonna have to subtract 2l from P
in order for the Equality to to keep
being true so the left-hand side is
going to be P minus 2l minus 2l and then
that is going to be equal to well 2l
minus 2l the whole reason why we
subtract a 2 LS because these are going
to cancel out so these cancel out and
you're just left with a 2 w here you're
just left with a 2w we're almost there
we've almost solved for W to finish it
up we just have to divide both sides of
this equation by 2 and the whole reason
why I'm dividing both sides of this
equation by 2 is to get rid of this two
coefficient this 2 that's multiplying W
so if you divide both sides of this
equation by 2 once again if you do
something to one side of the equation
you do it to the other side the whole
reason why I divided the right-hand side
by 2 is 2 times anything divided by 2 is
just going to be that anything so this
is going to be a W and then we have our
left-hand side so we're done if we just
flop if we flip these two sides we have
our W we have our W will be equal to
this thing over here equals P minus 2l
minus 2l all of that over all of that
over 2 now this is the correct answer
there's other ways to write it though
you might want to rewrite this so let me
square this off because this is
completely the correct answer this is
the correct answer but there's other
ways that you might have been able to
get this answer or other expressions for
this answer you might have also you know
another completely legitimate way to do
this problem let me write it this way so
our original problem is P is equal to 2l
plus 2w is on this right hand side what
if we factor out a 2 so we get
make is clear you have a to here and you
have a to here so you can imagine
undistributing the to so we would get P
is equal to 2 times L plus W this is an
equally legitimate way to do this
problem now we can divide both sides of
this equation by 2 so that we get rid of
this 2 on the right hand side so if you
divide both sides of this equation by 2
these twos are going to cancel out 2
times anything divided by 2 is just
going to be anything is equal to P over
2 so let me just rewrite this over here
let me just rewrite this so we will get
P over 2 P over 2 is going to be equal
to L plus W L plus W and then if we want
to solve for W we just subtract L from
both sides and sometimes you can write
it in a separate line like this
sometimes you could just write it like
this you could say I'm going to subtract
an L on that side if I do it on that
side I have to do it on this side too
that's the same thing as adding a
negative L and so the right hand side
you're just left with aw you're just
left with a W and then the left hand
side you're going to have it could be a
negative L plus P over 2 or you could
just you could just change the order and
you can write this as P over 2 P over 2
minus L and this is also an equally
legitimate answer and you're probably
saying hey Sal wait these things look
different P minus 2l over 2 that looks
different than P over 2 minus L and
they're not think about this we could
rewrite this as P let me do the same
colors this over here this over here is
the same thing as P over over 2 P over 2
minus 2l over over to write 5 a minus B
and they're both being divided by 2 I
can just separate I can you can imagine
I'm distributing the division by 2
right over here and over here 2 times L
divided by 2 that's just an L so this is
going to be equal to P over 2 minus L
minus L which is the exact same thing as
this right there